we're seeing new evidence of the scale
of devastation from saturday's
earthquake in haiti what were
what were once buildings are now just
splintered piles of rubble as you can
see in these pictures here in some cases
entire homes have been swallowed up by
the earth our vlad duties flew into
areas destroyed by the disaster
our flight into the quake zone could not
prepare us for the destruction down
below
once we arrived in lake high the
devastation surrounded us homes and
businesses unrecognizable to those who
call this city home i'm standing atop
what used to be a four-story hotel on
saturday when the earthquake struck
multiple people were crushed and killed
including a former haitian senator and
that's the thing about earthquakes they
don't discriminate
about 10 miles from lakhai sits the
small village of manish where the damage
was even more profound made even worse
by the battering rain from tropical
depression grace
driving through the town we saw hundreds
of villagers roaming outside without a
place to call home this car was
completely flattened when this house
collapsed essentially pancaking it
across the street here this catholic
church has stood in manish for over a
hundred years it's been utterly
destroyed and now due to the aftershocks
is a real fear that this tower could
come crashing down and hurt more people
for those already injured help is a
world away
we showed you how victims of the
earthquake are being ferried to
hospitals in port-au-prince
here's why
this is what's left of the only hospital
in manish
the town's mayor david
says about 98 percent of manish was
destroyed
they need water and they need food
and they need assistance with the
sanitary conditions this is exactly what
leads to disease
we spoke to me
whose sister died in the quake
she says many villagers have simply lost
hope miyai says that she's seen that the
focus has been on the bigger cities in
haiti that were affected by the
earthquake but here in manish no one has
paid a lot of attention to them they
feel left behind they feel as if no one
is coming for them
the damage was amplified by tropical
depression grace which caused mudslides
and some rivers to swell that's cut off
some of the most remote villages from
getting any aid at all and gail it's
unclear how and when they could receive
it all right vladimir dutia reporting
from haiti thank you vlad